alors Aurélien était un un enfant enfin
un garçon très gentil avec ses parents
très gentil avec son épouse et son petit
garçon très très joyeux qui aimait la
vie enfin qui aime toujours la vie
d'ailleurs et qui pose aucun problème
enfin qui tout se passait bien et sinon
bah il faisait un petit peu de sport je
pense c'était un grand amateur de moto
bon c'est je sais que l'accident ne
l'empêche pas de toujours aimer ça mais
bon je pense qu'il pourra pas en refaire
et ce que j'espère qu'il ne refera
pas en 3 minutes notre vie a basculé
et pour nous ça a été terrible on s'est
dit plusieurs fois pourquoi nous et pas
les autres même si on le souhaite pas
mais c'était terrible je pense que voilà
on le souhaite à personne et enfin moi
je sais que j'ai beaucoup de mal à à M
remettre et même si aujourd'hui on voit
en très bonne
santé entre guillemets si on le voit
évoluer correctement on se dit que voilà
sa vie sera quand même pas comme elle
était avant même s'il va vivre avec son
handicap mais c'est pas
facile il a fallu se dire qu'on avait
d'autres enfants aussi et qu'il fallait
pas les oublier
donc on essaie de de vivre tout
simplement faites attention surtout même
si vous si vous avez un accident avec un
motard arrêtez-vous surtout même si pour
vous la vie va être enfin si elle aura
certainement des conséquences mais
arrêtez-vous ne faites pas comme le la
personne qui a qui
a enfin qui a accroché Aurélien
arrêtez-vous
surtout